okay real quick we had a lot of requests
from fans you in fact are not married or
engaged yeah
okay we don't know anything else because
technically you are legally your legal
status is single and we have a system
here little-known fact one of our
regular guests Gerald is a mechanical
engineer him and not gay Jarrod have a
patent on a machine where we will input
information we're going to ask you a
series of questions and from everybody
on the face of the earth it's going to
narrow it down to your scientifically
perfect match I think any questions I'm
excited and a little nervous so let's do
it yeah it's one match so this will I
don't know how many men there are three
billion there's a lot there's a lot yeah
probably more than a dozen I would
assume they discount like the guy who
played the Somali pirate actor from well
we hope so but no they're in the mix
okay let's let's bring in the system now
little-known fact the dream machine is a
little tone deaf
not the best not very good at the best
that's not the point here okay so I'm
going to ask you a series of questions
Tommy first question your perfect man is
he above or below six-foot okay we got
it we got it okay second question your
ideal man would you consider him to be
rugged or pretty right rugged okay put
that in there dear I think he's got it
we got that in there that in there okay
your ideal man Tommy
would he have brown hair blond hair red
hair or you prefer not to answer I mean
I hate to go on with your Hitler you
thing but probably blond hair I'm sorry
light
okay Santi information okay me it's got
it
it sounds free but yeah one other I
should list a caveat it also detects
home it's it's down there stop at dream
machine this is a nice lady it's trying
one caveat you may even be wrong about
what you want and it'll actually pick up
through vocal it's kind of like a
lie-detector test it picks up so you you
know you could be wrong maybe you want
to go with brown hair I thought I'd like
to UM with brown hair and my wife has
blonde hair okay we have two more
questions here ideal man his political
world view would it have to be
conservative left-wing or undisclosed
preferably conservatives
yeah I'm still conservative okay in here
okay what is that stop it with that
dream machine that's enough this is not
just a nice lady that was that was a
this is a scientific patent eyes that's
what they said that's what the box okay
final question this ideal man is he
self-employed or employed by somebody
else ensuring financial security I guess
the question is what's more important
someone who is individualistic or
provides security security yeah security
I'm surprised
why I don't know I think it's I think
it's about ready I think it's okay do we
have a perfect match is it giving you an
out somebody here okay Sammy line we
have your perfect match are you ready
why I'm so excited yes alright
scientific magic right that stuff you're
perfect
three matches Dean Cain Wow Dean Cain I
didn't know why didn't did you did you
expect that I do Superman Lois and Clark
a popular television series in the 1990
okay we get a dream you know Dean Cain
is right yeah absolutely
you know known fact being paid is also a
super athlete we played football on
scholarship at Princeton impressing the
crowds and winning their hearts it
sounds like we know where she's at Dean
Cain dm's you because he's a friend of
the show he's doing here before in the
past okay
order I didn't know broseph that's
impressive though when you have the
Machine some another just it doesn't
know that it just keeps giving you
information so would you say would you
be if we could set it up on the show
would you have a conversation with Dean
King because we could make that happen
sounds good I mean okay I can't I get it
even though there's you know that I
thought I honestly didn't know I did you
know that about Dean Cain the last part
everything also the paint postive know
it or not I didn't know that either
apparently is that he's a man okay I get
it
there we go I didn't really mean I we
get a dream machine you like now you
don't being pain okay Jared can you shut
it off can you have you go so I'm sorry
tell me I'm sorry do not same athletic
nor I think just unplug it I don't know
where the pisser
sorry Tommy I'm rather sorry about that
okay
it could be ready much it was very
forceful I mean generator power maintain
also provides the genes necessary I'm
sorry stop what you do I think it's I
think it's fixed I think they await for
the 2.0 model wait Tommy I am so sorry
it was unbelievably unprofessional
inappropriate back to the point Dean
Cain you said that UDM Dean Cain were
you aware he was conservative yes
absolutely and does he sound what's
gonna be in your wheelhouse I mean you
know he was on TV in the 90s I was born
in the 90s maybe I got slight bit too
young but hey you never know
congratulations you've not yet been
corrupted by the internet and your short
attention span I know mine went away
with dramatic hamster and then it was
just solidified with history of dance
that guy could really do the Ice Ice
Baby here's the thing you may not know
this is a clip from a full three hour
radio show you can see that full show by
clicking next to me I think there's
something else playing in another box it
might be another short video I don't
know I can't be bothered to do my
research you're still here